so much happened so quickly we can all
agree cgi is a marvel movie's best
friend dr strange in the multiverse of
madness takes that concept to the next
level using a ton of visual effects so
let's hop through the portal and take a
look at those impressive scenes
number one if you didn't like this movie
for whatever reason we think you can
agree with us that this scene was pretty
amazing as doctor strange grabs america
into a multiverse portal they fall
through the most random universes of
course there's not a whole lot of
practical things vfx artists could have
done here so this scene had to be
completely cgi we would have thought
there'd at least be the actors in front
of a blue screen but those close-ups on
benedict cumberbatch were all
convincingly digital the process to make
this moment was very tedious for artists
as they had to make each environment
more unique than the last pretty
impressive stuff here but the real
madness comes from those couple of
scenes in the paint reality
professionals that are in visual effects
can tell you how difficult it is to work
with liquid physics i think the whole
thing was challenging because there's so
many elements that go from shot to shot
number two only doctor strange could
concoct a trap fit enough to distract an
evil witch but don't be fooled here this
moment was entirely digital unlike our
last entry production coordinators did
indeed have the real elizabeth olsen
here but that was as real as it gets the
only real behind the scenes look we have
here is an amazing looking contraption
spinning around olson as she stands in
front of a backdrop
as simple as that was to shoot producing
the mirror environment around her was a
whole other feat
number three the opening of any movie
needs to be able to grab the audience's
attention and as multiverse of madness
begins so does the maddening cgi work
for vfx artists the whole environment
produced in the scene was 100 digital
set designers built a massive green
sound stage and a little strip for the
actors to sprint down
number four why not include a little
demon fight in a sam raimi horror film
as strange attempts to dreamwalk into
zombie strange christine now has to
complete the mission every common gamer
loathes protect the hero until the timer
runs out now knowing that it would be
pretty dangerous for the director to
include real-life demon bats rachel
mcadams had to beef up her cgi chops and
fight with the air
number five a broken reality needs a lot
of cgi to fix it back up in the scene
where strange and christine find
themselves trapped in a broken reality
everything is quite literally turned on
its side artists had a lot of background
work to get done in order to make up the
chaos some practical pieces were added
like the floating car and building
structures it must have been a real
change for the vfx team to actually get
permission to go as wild and unexplained
as possible here
number six it takes a while for some
people to get with the digital craze and
for some of the members of the
illuminati they went full cgi with their
outfits surprisingly the suits reed
richards and black bolt dawned were
entirely digital to get the task done
vfx coordinators crafted skin tight
suits covered in trackers to make sure
the digital makeup stayed put on their
bodies but the work doesn't end there
the big fight scene against the scarlet
witch was not even done with all the
actors in the same room we don't know if
it was due to scheduling or the pandemic
but they basically had only two to three
actors communicating in real time on set
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool
number seven you've gotta keep both eyes
open for this one especially if you're
cumberbatch or you'll miss nothing on
set in terms of cg monsters this beast
was very well done if only the actors
could have seen it in real life stun
coordinators had to work endlessly with
the vfx team in order to make sure
everything matched up adding as much
practicality as possible before anything
got too dangerous or destructive on set
number 8. possessing a zombie is a
little extreme for a marvel movie but if
you hire sam raimi to direct nothing's
too extreme for the zombie scene set
designers built a massive stage with
blue backdrops and a really impressive
cliff as filming on location for that
scene would have been dangerous they
went for as much digital here as
possible not just on the environment but
even zombie strange got a bit of work
done on his face in post-production i
wanted that character
to have conflict
number nine the space between realities
needed to look as trippy as possible so
no use of practical effects were
necessary here all of this is pure cgi
with the help of a few actors to sell
the scene it's fitting for an
environment between realities to really
have no sense of reality at all
number 10 you know we're all about that
cgi cape no practical if that little
joke flew by your heads no worries maybe
let strange's cape do the explaining
since a lot of what our hero does is
with a flying and somewhat conscious
cape it'll need a whole lot of digital
and in this case it looks like even when
he was stationary the cape was not made
practically there are a lot of moments
on set where we can see benedict
strolling around with one over his
shoulders so it's super cool that they
keep us guessing when it's real or not
number 11 look at all those layers when
america was able to punch like a
superhero it always made for a pretty
stunning visual effects artist really
broke down the visual of the punch
adding on layers and layers putting the
super in superhero punch this one in
particular was a little more tedious
because of the fact that america was
punching a glass like cell but at this
point shattering glass effects are a
no-brainer for these professionals to
achieve
number 12. talk about catfishing a
sorcerer when the scarlet witch reveals
her true evil colors to strange the
entire environment becomes void of all
life the light is taken away to reveal
an evil red landscape not that this was
the most difficult effect to achieve or
anything but this was super interesting
to see behind the scenes by just adding
a touch of red and throwing the actors
in front of a backdrop they were able to
change the tone of the scene almost
effortlessly sometimes you just gotta
take the digital shortcut and with
marvel vfx artists they deserve a few
breaks every once in a while
number 13 benedict stop hitting yourself
stop hitting yourself when a scene calls
for two different versions of an actor
to interact with each other the most
simple way of doing it is just splitting
them up on the frame for different takes
but fighting each other with close-ups
not so simple with the spells being a
big factor vfx artists now had to
seamlessly match up the cgi needed to
fill in the scene's environment luckily
production hired a stunt double to
execute it more practically but getting
those moments synced up effectively is
all thanks to those editors and cgi
artists
number 14 if you've watched some of our
previous doctor strange videos you'll
know that the siege of carmitage was
definitely the heftiest one on
production all those different sound
stages were built perfectly to coincide
with each other however none of this
could have been held together without a
little digital glue all the magic spells
and environments were executed in post
blending in with the practical sets and
lighting without each of these aspects
working hand in hand this scene would
have not turned out the way it did it
was a great collaboration between
special effects stunts camera crews
number 15 wanda is no stranger to
creating imaginary worlds but she
couldn't have done this one without a
little help from cgi while a lot of the
dark hold is indeed practical there are
always bits of the environment that need
a little digital touch up artists worked
on the background of this one a lot
adding in a few spell effects as well
it's hard to believe cgi sometimes but
marvel has only proved how far that
technology has come with the rollout of
multiverse of madness so put on those
imagination capes if you were in a
marvel movie what's the one effect you'd
want the artist to do to you let us know
in the comments